brought to you by t-mobile
now Netflix is included another reason
why t-mobile is America's best unlimited
network
what is dead may rise again and the past
cannot stay buried for long
so when universal needed a cinematic
universe they dug up the rotting bloated
corpse of the mummy experience the
terror of a film without a soul that
likes the fun of the brendan fraiser
version missus the horror of the
original and settles into its own still
blend of action blockbuster cliches that
manage to kill all hype for the dark
universe before it even began
cuz when you want to murder a franchise
by cramming it full of spin off bait you
get the guy who did the exact same thing
to spider-man Oh Matt Kurtzman uses his
powers for good and writes a
Transformers movie oh he did twice huh
The Mummy is back and she's all hot now
complete with sexy henna tattoos
strategically rotting bandages to keep a
pg-13 rating and the power to suck you
dry she's back to take revenge on the
world after they punished her for making
a deal with the devil a deal that gave
her the power to kill two sleeping
people and a baby huh not sure you had
to bring the devil into that and the
only way to stop her is to resurrect
that god of death by pairing the magic
dagger with a super Jam then kill the
host before the ritual is complete and
like this is exactly why people don't go
to the movies anymore journey to Egypt
for a few minutes then journey to London
because it's way cheaper to shoot there
and meet Nick Morton a younger man proof
that some people are such boring dicks
that even Tom Cruise can make them
charming
watch him bumble from action scene to
exposition dub without pausing to
develop his character beyond
home-schooled Indiana Jones was writing
on her Glee effects respectfully I'm not
interested in no archeological chart in
this rare cruise misfire that plays
against his greatest strength as an
actor you can't run
sorry broski Tom's got a ride it's in
his contract right next to the Hank from
something Klaus
sit through this loose collection of
studio notes masquerading as a single
movie that somehow manages to talk down
to you new stone no virtually no ritual
no curse well also being so vague and
sloppy you don't know what's going on
half the time thank you for bringing me
back to life and everything Nick but
what are we even doing here where are we
going with one unholy purpose holding it
all together make the dark universe
happen as this movie about a mummy stops
dead in its tracks to introduce its own
version of Nick Fury
my name is Jekyll dr. Henry Jekyll
its own version of shield welcome to
prediction and it's very own haul of
spin-offs oh hey I spied the creature
from the black wooden arm over there
my grandpa would've been so excited he
was still alive miss you pop-up so if
the prospect of an action movie universe
starring guys in their 50s fighting
monsters from the 30s excites you saddle
up for the first and potentially last
time you'll get to see it before
Universal gets the crazy idea - and I
know this is nuts but just hear me out
actually do something scary and original
with a horror movie
get out I don't believe it starring and
enf owns it in an American ripoff in
London doctor lady MD findin monster's
findin monsters fighting round the world
a waste of a perfectly good Courtney be
Vance this is thriller thriller night a
swarm of spiders a swarm of rats a swarm
of birds a swarm of terrible reviews and
Brendan Fraser oh how I would have been
to throw the guy cameo where is he these
days
Tom Cruise runs from sand featuring the
mummy this movie was so rushed they
accidentally posted the trailer without
music or sound effects yes this is real
brought to you by t-mobile America's
best unlimited network just upped its
game by including Netflix with your
family plan switch today a wolf with
Dragon's Blood
you'll flow - you'll flow - you'll float
- something-something Star Wars
something Marvel something Internet me
something political